francia italia alemania y bélgica son
algunos de los países que empezaron a
restringir el ingreso de pasajeros del
reino unido- luego de que se confirmara
la aparición de una nueva variante del
cob y 19 que se puede propagar hasta en
un 70% más rápido que la original
el gobierno nacional defendió hoy la
imposición de un nuevo confinamiento con
más restricciones al contacto humano
especialmente en londres y en el sureste
del país donde prácticamente las
festividades de navidad han sido
canceladas diciendo que había que poner
este virus bajo control el ministro de
salud más hancock dijo que la vacunación
solo cuando esté tan avanzada que haga
una diferencia en la situación podría
permitir que se revisarán las medidas
mientras tanto no el gobierno entretanto
les ha pedido a los ciudadanos que en
estas festividades de navidad y de fin
de año se mantengan en las casas